CUNNINGHAM: Well, good morning.
I'm Nelson Cunningham.
I'm the president of McLarty Associates.
And I'll be presiding here at this morning's
session.
Unlike most Council sessions, this one is
on the record.
You'll see the cameras here.
There's some reporters in the room.
We do ask you to silence-to turn off your
mobile phones, because it interferes with
the sound system.
We'll be-I'll introduce the vice president,
we'll spend-she and I-she'll make some remarks,
she and I will spend until about 9:00 in a
dialogue, and then we'll open it to the audience,
as it typical here at the Council.
For me, it's a privilege, of course, to preside
at any CFR event, but this one is a special
one for me, because my family lived in Panama
for six years when I was a boy, my father
was a businessman in Panama City.
He founded the American Chamber there almost
40 years ago.
And for us, Panama has a very special place
in my family's life.
And I'm fortunate today, and for the last
20 years, to be involved in U.S.-Latin American
relations.
And Panama, of course, has played such an
important role at key moments there.
So it's a pleasure for me to be able to be
here to introduce the vice president.
Vice President Saint Malo has a very international
background.
She, of course, was raised in Panama, studied
in the United States for both college and
for her business degree, and then spent 15
years in Panama working for the U.N. Development
Program as the country manager there.
In that role, she spent a great deal of time
both in Panama, and then dealing around the
world with multilateral issues.
And I understand that she got to know the
current president, President Varela, during
that time, working with him on various dialogues
dealing with the canal and other issues.
And so someone who came out of the multilateral
world, out of the business world, found herself
pulled into the political world.
So you bring-you bring a great deal of experience
and breadth to this position.
As is common in Panama-although you are of
course the constitutional vice president-but
as is common in Panama, the president also
asked you to take a second role as foreign
minister.
And you now carry out that role.
So you're here today in two capacities.
It's a real pleasure to be able to introduce
to all of you Vice President Isabel de Saint
Malo.
(Applause.)
SAINT MALO: Thank you very much, Nelson, for
those kind words.
I was walking in and he greeted me in Spanish.
And I said, wow, where is that Spanish from?
(Laughs.)
And he said: I've lived in Panama.
So it's a pleasure to be sharing this podium
with you.
Good morning, everybody.
It's really an honor to be here today.
I've been actually an admirer of the Council's
work for a long time, first as a student of
international affairs, then when I began my
career actually here in Washington, D.C. with
the Center for Democracy, and later on as
a practitioner of development and of democracy,
and now of diplomacy.
You definitely make great contributions to
policymaking in terms of foreign policy.
And that's-I think that's very important.
So it's an honor to be here today.
I've been told that the objective is to have
a conversation.
So I'll try to be brief in these remarks so
that we move onto the interesting part of
the morning, which is the conversation with
you.
I'll try to make some remarks to let you know
a little bit more about my country where we
are right now.
And I'd like to begin by referring to Panama
as a global place.
And I like to say, Panama has been globalized
before globalization was in fashion.
And that's actually true.
Ever since we were-we were born as a republic,
we've been-we've been a crossroads of people,
of trade.
And with the Porto Bello (sp) affairs, and
then through the gold rush, and then, of course,
the Panama Canal.
And that has really made us who we are as
a country, a country really open to the world.
And this has been kind of like the basis of
one of the principles of our foreign policy
and our domestic policy in terms of our ability
of bringing people together.
Latin America enjoys today democracy, pretty
much.
And not too long ago I'm sure around these
tables discussion of the dictatorships that
were taking place in the region were happening
every day.
The guerilla warfare, we don't have that now.
Fortunately, Panama has been part of that
democratization of the region.
We are proud to have been-recuperated our
democracy.
And for the past 25 years, we've had already
five democratically elected governments.
And we enjoy democracy.
Panama, our country, our people, we value
democracy.
We value freedom of expression.
We value a market economy, providing opportunities
to all of those that wish to seize those opportunities.
In terms of our economy, we have a very diversified
economy.
According to the IMF, we are ranked third
as the most economically prosperous country
in Latin America.
In terms of the World Economic Forum we rank
second in terms of competitiveness.
In the past 10 years, we've enjoyed a growth
of 7.6 percent, making it one of the fastest-growing
economies in Latin America.
Even during the difficult years, recently,
Panama managed to continue to grow.
We grew over 6 percent last year.
Our projects for this year are also over 6
percent.
And of course, the Panama Canal, which we
are very proud to be inaugurating this year
the enlarged Panama Canal, makes and important
part of our economy.
However, our economy is very diversified and
we do not depend on any particular sector
of the economy.
Our canal is complemented by a worldwide platform
of logistics and services.
One of the best ports and airports in the
region are in Panama.
And with the expanded canal, which we are
proud to be inaugurating June 26th, capacity
will triple in terms of volumetric capacity
to transit through the canal.
And I was actually yesterday at the-at the
Energy Summit chaired by Vice President Biden.
And we were discussing what this canal will
offer in terms of the possibility of transit
to LNG vessels from the United States Gulf
Coast to Asia.
So all of this, and given the difficulties
of energy in the region and the efforts for
integration, there are great opportunities
and also possibilities for Panama to once
again put our country to the service of the
world, to the service of trade, and of development
in the region.
Amidst this growth in economic terms, amidst
our democracy, which we are proud to have
recuperated, you would ask where are our challenges?
And we do have important challenges in terms
of development, particularly.
Our challenges remain in terms of overcoming
poverty, in terms of improving social indicators.
And that is actually the core of our government
plan.
Our five-year government plan is concentrated
in providing these opportunities to almost
4 million Panamanians.
We have development budget of over $17 million,
devoted primarily to education, to health.
We've come a long way in terms of our poverty
indicators-a long way.
But we still have important steps to take.
And that is our concentration of our-of our
government.
A country that grows, a country that has the
economic indicators that we have, a country
that serves the world has all of the necessary
capabilities to make this available to all
Panamanians.
And that is what we're working at.
That is our concentration.
And these investments in social and infrastructure
projects will definitely help us deepen our
social welfare, increase stability, expand
human capital, and further develop our infrastructure.
In terms of our foreign policy, we base our
foreign policy on two pillars.
The first pillar being a country that promotes
dialogue, that promotes understanding.
This has been part of our foreign policy for
many years.
It's kind of who we are as a country, as a
result of having been the crossroads of the
Americas and of the world for a long time.
An example of this vision was the Summit of
the Americas, which we were proud to host
last year, and which allowed for the participation
of all countries from the Americas for the
first time ever in the Summit of the Americas.
I was that the-our effort was part of that
vision of Panama as a country that promotes
dialogue, that promotes understanding.
Our second pillar in terms of foreign policy
is to have an active participation in the
global development agenda.
And we have been very, very active in this
government in terms of, for example, of human
rights, which led to have a seat for the first
time.
We were able to have a Panamanian elected
to the Inter-American Commission of Human
Rights for the first time ever.
We were elected at the United Nations Commission
on Human Rights, also for the first time.
And our participation in the Sustainable Development
Goals, which were agreed upon by many countries
last year at the United Nations General Assembly,
it's not only a commitment in terms of the
global development agenda, but it's at the
core of our national government plan.
We have actually decided by decree that the
SDGs will guide Panama's investments and Panama's
social efforts.
So in this regard, there is a complete alignment
with the global development agenda and our
domestic policy.
Our participation in the Paris agreement.
Panama even led an effort in terms of the
countries that have forest, and the efforts
that the world needs to make in order to ensure
that those countries that have forest can
keep them, and the contribution that this
makes to climate change.
All of this is, again, a result of this importance
that we give to the global development agenda,
understanding that that is where the world
needs to concentrate its attention.
We need, as a world, to overcome the issues
of today, the issues of people migrating from
countries where there is war and where there
is lack of opportunities, to developed countries.
The issues of human rights, which still today
are violated in many parts of the world.
The issues of incorporating those excluded
from development into development.
We see these not as an issue that is apart
from our core domestic policy.
And we see Panama as a country that can play
a role in order to continue to push those
efforts.
Now, we are today in the mind frame of many
people not for everything that I've shared
with you.
We are at the top of mind of many people because
of some publications that came out about a
month ago, already.
It seems like a year ago-(laughter)-so much
has happened ever since-ever since that came
out.
Let me tell you something about the wrongfully
called Panama Papers.
And I'm sure they were named Panama Papers
because Panama is a great name.
(Laughter.)
Panama is a great name.
And this journalist needed to have a great
name for their publications.
And, you know, that's our problem for having
a great name.
But the fact of the matter is that, yes, the
publications referred to business conducted
by a law firm in Panama.
But furthermore, the publications refer to
dealings of banks in 21 jurisdictions, none
of them in Panama.
Not one of the banks that have been mentioned
in those publications is based in Panama.
The publications referred to offshores.
Twenty percent of those, registered in Panama.
Eighty percent of those, registered elsewhere-British
colonies, United States, everywhere.
The publications really underline that there
is a global problem in terms of the financial
system, something that the world has recognized
for a long time and this publication just
make it clear that we still have a long way
to go.
We still have a long way to go as a world.
It's been hard on Panama that the publications
are named Panama Papers.
It's been very hard, particularly for our
government.
I must admit that Panama, as a country, we
came a little late to the efforts of transparency
for the financial sector.
When President Varela was vice president and
minister of foreign affairs, during the last
government, Panama had not signed one treaty
for double taxation.
And under his leadership, we established a
national commission, we initiated our signing
of and negotiating of double taxation agreements.
And we signed about 25 at that period of time.
And then the alliance broke.
And then he left the government.
And then the previous government didn't do
much in terms of this global effort.
And when we took office two years ago, Panama
was on the gray list of the FATF because we
had failed to comply with some of the global
efforts.
And we initiated a strategy which moved so
fast, even recognized so by the FATF.
I heard them at a meeting in Panama say that
they had never seen a country move so fast
in terms of the decisions that need to be
made and the processes that need to be put
in place in terms of transparency.
And we were able to be removed last year from
FATF's gray list as a result of Panama implementing
anti-money laundering legislation, prevention
of money from terrorism into our financial
services.
We installed the governance institutions that
we needed to install.
And we got our act together.
And we were able to be removed from the gray
list.
And we were able to move to the phase two
of the peer review of the OECD.
So all of these efforts that our government
has been doing, and that have been recognized
globally because FATF's decision to remove
us from the list is a recognition of our efforts
and the OECD's transition to phase two of
the peer review is a recognition of our country's
efforts, it's hit hard by some publications
that have our name, because our name is pretty
nice.
(Laughter.)
So we have been in an effort to, again, share
with the world what it is that we're doing.
And, yes, there are problems with the financial
system around the world, problems of which
Panama must be a part of its solution, but
the rest of the world as well.
And we will continue to work in that direction.
We are committed, not because of the Panama
Papers.
We were committed the day we took office.
And the actions we've taken speak for themselves.
But I wanted to take this opportunity to let
you know our vision on these publications
and what it is that our vision is in terms
of transparency in the financial sector, transparency
in general.
Transparency has been at the core of our government
plan.
Procurement in the past years in Panama has
been known.
And actually, the justice system can say a
few things in that regard.
Procurement in Panama was really permeated
by corrupt practices.
We have really, really cleaned Panama's act
in that regard.
And you can ask foreign companies now what
it is to invest in our government investment
plan.
And we know what it was to invest previously.
So our commitment to transparency in the financial
services, in our procurement processes, we
are committed to changing politics in Panama
to really be what politics needs to be-a service
to the people.
Politics-not to have a personal agenda, not
to enrich yourself, politics to be a tool
to serve the people and to serve the country.
So our commitment is strong.
Our commitment, once again, I would like to
reiterate, is not the result of responding
to some publications.
Our commitment has been clear ever since we
took office.
The measures taken speak for themselves.
And as I began sharing with you, Panama is
a lot more than that.
Panama is a country that enjoys democracy,
that enjoys freedom of expression, that enjoys
economic growth that is fighting to ensure
that this economic growth transform into the
improvement of life of all Panamanians.
And we've seen some important progress in
that regard in terms of education, in terms
of health, in terms of water, and sanitation.
And our success story is there.
I invite you all to come see for yourself.
And more than that, we are truly committed
to continue to make Panama a country that
shares this prosperity with the rest of the
region, and that ensures that this prosperity
permeates not only Panama, but our neighbors
that have difficulties a lot harder than we
have.
And we are working hard in terms of our foreign
policy to play that role and make sure that
the global development agenda, which guides
multilateralism and foreign policy in many
ways, really reaches the people of Central
America, of Latin America.
And that's what we're committed to do.
Thank you very much for your attention.
(Applause.)
CUNNINGHAM: Madam Vice President, you touched
on one of the issues that I know has been
on the forefront of the minds of those here,
which is the transparency issues in Panama.
Your boss, your president, President Varela,
as you mentioned, was vice president in the
prior administration, was foreign minister,
and had a very notorious split with President
Martinelli because Vice President Varela no
longer had confidence in the way President
Martinelli was governing the country when
it came to transparency and corruption issues.
And he was, of course, relieved of his duties
as foreign minister, but he could not be relieved
of his duties as vice president.
So he had an empty desk for a number of years,
which prepared him well to take on the role
of running-again, running for president, and
now serving as president.
President Martinelli, meanwhile, former President
Martinelli is living in Miami.
SAINT MALO: What can I tell you?
CUNNINGHAM: Your government has-your Supreme
Court has issued some charges against him.
I know you have an extradition request pending.
There may be further charges-if one reads
the newspapers-there may be further charges
coming.
What can you tell us about the status of President
Martinelli here in the U.S. and your efforts
to bring him to justice in Panama?
SAINT MALO: Interesting question.
As you have mentioned, our Supreme Court has
a few cases pending on Mr. Martinelli, former
President Martinelli.
One of those-which is for the issue of rigging
telephone conversations-one of those has been
approved by the board of the Supreme Court
to, under that-under those charges request
the extradition to the United States.
Now, in terms of Panamanian legal framework,
the Supreme Court needs to prepare the extradition
request and submit it to the Ministry of Foreign
Affairs.
And then the Ministry of Foreign Affairs will
be responsible for transferring that request
to the United States.
We have not yet received from the Supreme
Court that request for extradition.
Now, we've of course evaluated and studied
the issue.
And it's a complicated situation.
We understand in terms of-first of all, our
extradition treaty with the United States
dates as far as the beginning of the 1900s.
So the crime by which the Supreme Court is
authorized to request the extradition is not
part of the treaty because, of course, at
that time, there were no telephones, so even
less there was a crime to listen to conversations.
Of course, this can all-and we've had discussions
with the United States authorities-of course,
this can be supported.
But that's an issue that we need to deal with.
The second issue is that according to the
treaty, if we request Mr. Martinelli's extradition
based on that case, we cannot judge him in
Panama for any other case.
And he-the cases-I believe it's almost 10
cases that are in the Supreme Court regarding
Mr. Martinelli right now.
And most of them are a lot more serious than
listening into conversations, which is serious
enough.
The charges are basically referring to corruption,
and his participation on corruption practices,
on our procurement processes, and even linked
to processes that are now at the judicial
system in the United States.
So another issue that I understand our Supreme
Court has is, how are we going to request
his extradition and make sure, in the dealings
with the United States, that we are not just
protecting him from future processes?
So those issues are critical issues there,
and as of-as we have been told by our Supreme
Court, and actually we've discussed, as mentioned,
with U.S. authorities, the importance of making
a very strong case so that the case doesn't
fall through the cracks in the United States
system.
And we do know that Mr. Martinelli has the
resources to hire knowledgeable lawyers, and
we understand he has hired a large number
of knowledgeable lawyers.
That's an issue for Panama.
We need to make sure that we can process him
properly for all of these issues.
Now, that's one thing, the request for extradition.
And I do hope that we will request his extradition
soon enough.
It's not in our hands, but we will definitely
go on with the process once we receive a request.
That is one thing.
But the second thing is what's happening in
the United States with the fact that former
President Martinelli is living in the United
States.
Now, I understand that your authorities cannot
mention, for example, if he has requested
asylum.
He might have.
Some of you might be lawyers and would probably
know better than I what happens in terms of
an extradition request if he's in an asylum
request process.
And I understand asylum request processes
can take as long as three years for a decision.
And I understand that once this is-this process
is going on, this person cannot be touched.
So, when and if Panama requests the extradition,
I don't know what's going to happen with the
United States system.
But what is-what is harder, I think, is not
this judicial situation that I do hope for
Panama's sake goes through.
But the thing is that this person is living
in the United States really just dedicated
to Panamanian politics through social media.
So I don't know, that is something that I'd
like to pose the question to you.
(Laughter.)
You know, it just blows my mind.
It blows my mind.
And I think-I think the world has a long way
to go to ensure that we stop protecting those
that should be brought to justice.
CUNNINGHAM: I want to commend you, in your-in
your remarks and just now, for the candor
in which you've addressed some of the most
complicated issues facing Panama today-the
Panama Papers, the issues with former President
Martinelli, the issues of development.
You mentioned also-but I think you swallowed
some of the good news, which is of course
the opening of the-of the new locks in the
Panama Canal.
Forty years ago here in the United States,
Panama was one of the hottest political topics
over President Carter's-over, actually, President
Ford and then President Carter's negotiation
of a treaty to return the Canal Zone to Panama
and to eventually turn over the management
of the Panama Canal to the Panamanians.
Those who may not have focused on Panama since
then might not know that Panama successfully
took over the management of the canal and
have had really an unimpeachable, for the
last 20 years-almost 20 years, management
of the canal, belying all of the fears and
concerns that had been raised at the time.
You've also gone ahead and then moved ahead
with a major expansion of the canal to permit
much larger vessels to go through.
Tell us how-and that will open in June, as
you mentioned.
Tell us how you expect that to impact Panama's
economy, as well as further the global shipping
lanes that go through Panama?
SAINT MALO: Thank you for that question, because
we are very proud in Panama to be inaugurating
our expanded canal June 26th.
And let me share with you what I think we're
most proud of.
And you've mentioned that we've successfully
assumed the administration of the canal, and
that it's recognized internationally by the
trade world and by other countries the transition
from U.S. management to Panamanian management
was imperceptible to the world.
That was-we've done it.
We've done it well.
But more than that, over a hundred years ago,
when we began the original canal, we had to
turn to the French and that we had to turn
to the United States, but this expansion was
done by Panama.
And if we look at the investment, which is
over 5,000 million dollars, in terms of dollars
in that time we're building a second canal.
This is a major infrastructure project, and
we are very proud to be inaugurating the canal,
and being a Panamanian-a Panamanian project
funded by Panama, led by Panama, contracted
by Panama.
And this just shows what Panama is capable
of.
And this will represent a major transition
to world trade.
I mentioned the LNG vessels, for example,
that will be able to transit through an enlarged
canal.
The administrator of the canal was just saying
a few days ago that ever since the inauguration
was announced, they have just been receiving
the bookings, and it's booked for its initiation.
The world-the maritime sector has been expecting
the expansion of the canal and were just there
ready to jump as soon as it was finalized,
and that's great news.
An enlarged canal will represent important
additional revenues for Panama.
One of the most important things from the
transfer-for the transfer of the canal to
Panamanian management is that, under U.S.
administration, the canal was managed-in terms
of its budget, it was managed-money that came
in, money that was-that came out.
There were no revenues for Panama, nor the
United States.
That was definitely changed when Panama assumed
administration, and the canal is today an
important source of income for our national
budget.
And an expanded canal will increase that dramatically.
And we are-we are waiting for those resources
in order to divert them to what I have mentioned
is our most important challenge, which is
development.
As mentioned earlier, our challenges in terms
of water and sanitation are amazing.
You go to Panama City-I don't know if you've
been recently; if you haven't been recently,
you should go-you go to Panama City, and Panama
City looks like New York City.
But in a country where we have a city that
is booming, we have sectors of our country
that are excluded.
And we're working hard at ensuring that our
human development indicators just jump, and
the resources that we will receive from an
expanded canal will definitely be diverted
into that-into that direction.
CUNNINGHAM: I'm going to turn now to the audience.
Those of you who have questions, I'll ask
you first to tell us who you are, what institution
you're with, and then to keep your questions
brief, fierce, and decisive.
Well, the press has an interest in asking
questions, so let me turn to the table here.
The woman in the-in the red jacket, please.
Q: Hi.
Welcome, Madam Secretary.
My name is Nadia Chow, Washington correspondent
for Liberty Times.
I have two question(s).
The first one is, for the inauguration, Panama
already extended an invitation to Taiwanese
President-elect Tsai Ing-wen and both Chinese
President Xi Jinping.
I wonder, are you expecting both of them to
attend?
Because Madam Tsai already expressed his (sic)
interest to, you know, participate.
The second question, the Panama Paper(s).
More detail were coming on Monday, next Monday,
and you said that Panama has been hit hard
by this paper.
Can you elaborate, you know, if more detail
is coming, what the impact will be on Panama's
economy?
Thank you.
SAINT MALO: Thank you very much.
On the first question, yes, we have extended
invitations to both the president of China
Taiwan and the president of People's Republic
of China.
Panama has diplomatic relations with Taiwan
and Panama has commercial relations with China.
We have an office in China.
We have an office in Hong Kong.
And we have an office in Taiwan.
And we have invited to the inauguration of
the Panama Canal the commercial sector of
the world, and we have invited heads of state.
Now, what has defined which heads of state
we have invited?
We invited about 40 heads of state.
The decision has been based primarily on those
countries that are the primary users of the
Panama Canal, and China is one of the primary
users of the Panama Canal.
So we would love to have them both, definitely.
This is-this is an event where Panama places
ourselves once again to the service of world
trade and world commerce, and we hope to share
this celebration with the rest of the countries
that participate of this-of this service that
Panama provides.
Regarding the second question, yes, we've
heard that there is a second round of information
coming.
I said Panama has been hit hard because it
bears Panama's name.
But many countries have been hit hard because
the information that has come out here touches,
as I mentioned, 21 jurisdictions in terms
of banking, many other jurisdictions in terms
of the registration of offshores, and furthermore,
people that have a public life all over the
world.
What can come of those-of those publications?
I would imagine more information on people
that have offshores or that have registered
businesses.
And we're just as expecting as the rest of
the world of these new publications.
CUNNINGHAM: Good.
Yes, here at the front table?
Q: Good morning.
Thank you for joining us.
Clara Brillembourg of the law firm Foley Hoag.
I wanted to ask, given Panama's historic role
as a leader in the region, and also given
your close relationship with the United States,
how the opening of the relationship between
the United States and Cuba has affected Panama.
SAINT MALO: The opening of the relationship
with the United States and Cuba, it's great
news to Latin America.
It's not only great news to Panama, but it's
great news to Latin America.
It was a-it was something that needed to happen
at some point.
We are very proud to have been the venue where
the president of the United States and the
president of Cuba met for the first time over
50 years.
And it's interesting that the last time they
had met before the Summit of the Americas,
the last time a president of the United States
and a president of Cuba had met, was in 1956
in Panama.
So we take pride in being a country that brings
people together, that brings countries together.
We have been open to the world forever.
Due to our geography, geographic location,
Panama has been a crossroads of people, of
culture, of trade.
And that has made us open to the world, and
that has made us a country that takes pride
in bringing people and countries together.
So that's great news, and we do hope it will
continue to move forward.
CUNNINGHAM: Let me ask a question that follows
on the one about the expansion of the Panama
Canal, because this-the opening of the canal
and the new locks actually touches on another
topic of global concern, because there may
not be enough water to fully power the locks
going forward, as I understand, at least for
the moment, because of El Nino.
It's-not everyone may know that one of the
miracles of the Panama Canal is that it's
fed entirely by the waters of the rain forest
in the interior of Panama.
There are no pumps.
It's not recirculated.
The water starts in the interior of Panama
and then flows through the locks into the
sea.
Because of El Nino, you've had a drought.
Some have linked El Nino, and this particularly
severe El Nino, to climate change.
What is Panama doing to both address the immediate
issue of the water that it needs for the locks
and the broader question of climate change?
SAINT MALO: Well, I'll begin with the second
question first, the broader question of climate
change.
As mentioned, we were very active in the negotiations
towards the Paris agreement.
We think that's great news to the world that
the world has finally reached an agreement
in terms of climate change.
The implementation will definitely be difficult.
There is a question here of the cost of taking
measures and who bears the cost.
When I mentioned the efforts of Panama, which
led-Panama led a coalition of 52 countries
towards the negotiations of the Paris agreement,
52 countries that have forest.
And the proposal of these 52 countries was
basically what do we do to conserve this forest,
and who foots the bill?
Because at the end there is a cost to development
when you commit to conserving your forests.
And forests are basically in the underdeveloped
world.
So countries like the United States will have
an important role to play in this effort towards
climate change.
Locally, we are doing a lot of things.
We have a strong leader of the efforts right
now in Panama, which is our minister of environment.
She's been an advocate of environment for
a long time.
She's been trained in environment, and she's
working in this regard.
We have a project of reforesting Panama, which
is going very well.
And we're just really turning around how we
manage environmental processes in Panama,
and we've really raised the commitment of
our government in terms of environment in
general.
Now, the water for the canal.
The issue is that the lakes that feed the
canal are also the lake that feed the Panamanian
population for drinking water.
So, yes, this is an important issue.
The good news is that the new canal does recirculate
water.
So the locks that were built at the beginning
of the last century, they were throwing that
water into the sea.
But the new locks work recirculating water.
So that's the good news.
We have-President Varela mentioned last year
at his speech at the National Assembly a project
that we need to look into soon, which is a
project to build further water reserves in
Panama.
And the lakes that feed the canal are manmade
lakes, are lakes that were made for the canal,
and they now provide the drinking water to
the city.
There is a lot of water in Panama.
We need to work at preserving this water.
And there is an area of Rio Indio where there
are several rivers come together.
And we're looking towards in the future just
building a large new water reservoir-reservoir.
Now, the other good news is that in Panama
we had El Nino.
But in Panama, when it starts raining, it
starts raining.
(Laughter.)
And last week it started raining, and then
we had floods.
(Laughs.)
So fortunately enough, the dry season has-it's
over.
The lakes will-how do you say that?
They will regain-
CUNNINGHAM: Replenish.
SAINT MALO: Replenish-thank you-replenish
with water.
But that's an issue that Panama needs to look
into for the future, the issue of water for
the canal and water for our population.
We're fine for the next-you know, for the
near future.
But long term we're already looking into additional
projects that will ensure the supply of water.
CUNNINGHAM: Yes, the gentleman at the back
table.
Q: Thank you.
Madam Secretary, this is Alex.
I am the Washington correspondent of United
Daily News of Taiwan.
I have a question with regard to diplomatic
tie between Panama and Taiwan.
We know Panama and China have robust economic
ties, which China have diplomatic tie with
Taiwan.
And Panama has been expressed its willingness
to establish diplomatic tie with China before.
And my question is, how would you describe
the diplomatic relations between Taiwan and
Panama at present?
And is so-called dual recognition a possible
way to figure out the diplomatic issue among
Panama, Taiwan, and China?
Thank you.
SAINT MALO: We have diplomatic relations with
Taiwan.
We have very good diplomatic relations.
We have, as I have mentioned, commercial relations
with China.
We understand the two Chinas have an agreement,
currently a truce, which we respect.
And we are very respectful of the way they
handle their relations and their rapprochement.
It's been a long process for them.
Meanwhile, we are friends of Taiwan and have
diplomatic relations with Taiwan.
And we have strong relations, commercial relations,
with China.
And we do hope that both of them will continue
to become stronger.
CUNNINGHAM: Yes, sir, over here.
Q: Hello.
Steve Rodriguez.
I'm a venture capitalist, but I spent some
time in the region with the U.S. Mil Group
in Colombia.
My question, Madam Vice President, is your
country sits at the crossroads of a number
of important issues related to terrorism,
epidemiology, and, of course, trade.
I guess my question is not so much getting
a current update of where things are.
I can read plenty of papers that have been
written here in D.C. on that.
My question is, how do you view your country's
role at the crossroads of so many of those
issues going forward?
SAINT MALO: Those issues that are global issues
are-we are having to face them, as well as
the rest of the world.
And I take the opportunity of your question
to refer to one particular issue, which is
difficult for us and which is a current affair,
in the situation of migrants going through
the isthmus on their way to the United States.
For the past years, many years, there have
been-there has been a flow of migrants through
the Central American isthmus to reach the
United States.
Now, the flow is made up of Cubans, many of
them wanting to reach the United States, given
the policy that the United States has of welcoming
Cuban migrants.
And there has also been a flow of people from
another continent.
There is a flow of people from Africa, from
Asia.
These people enter the continent, most of
them, through Brazil or Ecuador.
Brazil and Ecuador both have a migrant policy
that they're open to the world and they don't
require visas for many nationalities.
And I think it's a drama.
I think it's a human drama to have people
that flee their countries with their families.
We have people going with their young children.
We have pregnant women.
We have entire families.
And, you know, the issue of refugees in Europe,
it's very visible right now because they're
coming in large numbers.
The issue of migrants going through the Central
American isthmus towards the United States,
it's a smaller number than the refugees in
Europe so it's not as known.
But it's a human drama.
It's a human drama that people have situations
in their country in terms of wars, in terms
of lack of economic opportunities, that are
so dramatic that they're willing to risk everything
to find a better livelihood.
And I really think the world needs to look
into what's happening in these countries.
The response is not closing the gates, because
at some point I don't know if you can close
the gates.
I mean, look what's happening in Europe.
But I think the response needs to be a coherent,
integral response.
Addressing the issues of development and the
issues of peace are countries that are far
away from us, but that have these issues.
And the issue of migrants, right now we have
3,900 Cubans in Panama that cannot move to
Costa Rica because Costa Rica closed the frontiers.
And Costa Rica closed the frontiers because
Nicaragua closed the frontiers.
And we cannot close the frontiers with Colombia
because we don't have a frontier with Colombia.
We have a jungle on our frontier with Colombia.
So what are we to do?
Are we to move these families with four-,
three-, two-year children into the jungle,
which we actually did with a few of them a
couple of weeks ago, and a four-year-old got
lost?
And then we sent our police.
After sending our police to stop them from
coming in, we sent our police to look for
the kid, because what are you going to do,
ignore this human drama?
I mean, we cannot be a world talking about
a global agenda and talking about poverty
and talking about human rights at the tables
of the U.N. and then looking to the other
side when there are people that are willing
to risk everything because they have no future
at their original countries.
I don't see an easy response.
Panama is going to have to do something at
some point.
We're going to have to-I don't know-send Cubans
back to Cuba, send them to Ecuador, which
issued the visas.
They have Ecuadorian visas.
They don't have visas from Colombia.
They don't have visas from Panama.
We received about 400-a few months ago about
400, 390, people from Congo.
And we were, like, what?
Three hundred and ninety in one month?
We've had people from Senegal, from Congo;
you know, two, three.
They come through Brazil and they walk their
way up to the United States.
Can you believe this?
So we were, like, this doesn't make sense,
you know, 390.
Well, we have some agreements with the United
States and some systems to identify some people
through their-what do you call this, their-
CUNNINGHAM: Fingerprints.
SAINT MALO: -fingerprints, thank you, because
they claim they don't have papers.
They "lose" their papers because they don't
want to be sent back.
And if countries don't know where they're
from, you cannot send them back.
They were Haitians.
They were Haitians claiming to be from Congo.
So this is a human drama that the world needs
to start looking at.
And I don't think the result is to close the
gates.
I think the result is to push development
in those countries.
And I don't think we can any longer pretend
that this does not affect us, because we thrive
in development and economic prosperity because
this is not so far away when these people
are every day coming into our own countries.
CUNNINGHAM: Well, thank you for that very
articulate description of the issues involved.
Our country is about to embark on a-on a debate
on this very issue, a presidential debate.
And it's one of those who believes that America
is much stronger when it welcomes those from
around the world, I personally welcome your
articulate comment, although it was not intended
to be a comment at all affecting our own political
debate here.
Other questions?
Yes, sir, in the back.
Q: Hi, my name is Tony Perez.
I'm a-
CUNNINGHAM: Wait for the microphone, sir.
Q: Yeah, thank you.
My name is Tony Perez.
I'm a professor at Catholic University.
And earlier in my career, I had the lack of
fortune of working on international extradition
matters, so I was intrigued by your comment
about the Martinelli situation.
The United States for the last 30, 40 years
to my knowledge has been seeking to renegotiate
extradition treaties into the modern dual-criminality
format.
And I was wondering-if I understood you correctly,
Panama has not yet joined in that process,
and I was wondering if you're changing your
view about it, and whether or not you could
utilize that change to extradite Mr. Martinelli?
And the follow-up question is: Are you really
better off with Martinelli in Panama or in
Miami?
(Laughter.)
SAINT MALO: I don't know if I want to answer
your second question.
(Laughter.)
We would welcome the renegotiation of a treaty.
I don't think we have-we have a formal request.
We have not initiated a request.
Now, the negotiation of those agreements,
which need to be passed by our legislative
bodies, are not so quick.
So I don't know if we should be waiting for
that to deal with this and other cases.
We certainly could move into that direction
for the future.
And I take the Fifth Amendment on your second
question.
(Laughter, laughs.)
CUNNINGHAM: Yes, here at the back table.
Wait for the microphone, sir.
Thanks.
Q: So, thank you very much, Madam Vice President,
for being here.
And congratulations on the new government's
commitment to transparency and to development
issues.
So, my name's Itai Grinberg.
I'm at Georgetown Law.
Important, I guess, also relevantly, I was
previously at the United States Office of
International Tax Counsel, where I worked
on offshore tax evasion issues.
In prior governments, Panama developed a reputation
as being perhaps the most recalcitrant of
the major or significant financial intermediary
jurisdictions around the world with respect
to offshore tax evasion issues.
And in this government, you've only recently
joined the Common Reporting Standard, which
is kind of the new globally accepted standard
for what countries will do to try to address
offshore tax evasion.
I think you did that last week.
Given this history, I think there's sort of
this reputational question that Panama faces.
And the question is, just tangibly, are there
things Panama is prepared to do besides kind
of the bare minimum to get off the, OK, they're
different than everyone else list that you're
prepared to share with this audience?
So that would include, for example, changes
in rules about how lawyers and accountants
do due diligence, rules about beneficial ownership.
There are a variety of things that Panama
could do to change the way it's perceived.
I'm curious if you have any thoughts about
that.
SAINT MALO: Well, definitely.
And actually, some of the things that you've
mentioned we've already done in this past
20 months in government.
We have very strong know-your-client legislation
in Panama.
Actually, I invite you to go to Panama and
try to open a bank account.
It's a lot harder than opening a bank account
in the United States.
We have know-your-client legislation.
We have due diligence legislation.
The previous government approved a legislation
changing bearer shares and making it obligatory
for lawyers to know the end owners of shares.
And they passed that legislation and they
placed it in a hold for five years, until
2018 or something like that.
We reinstalled that legislation, which was
placed into effect January 1st this year.
So, today, important changes have been made
to our legislation.
Now, there is a question that I don't think
is that well-known in terms of our commitment
and in terms of our actions.
And I think it's something that needs to be
put into the table and just figure out how
we deal with it.
And it's part of our reality.
First of all, our taxing legislation, we do
not tax Panamanians for income generated outside
of Panama.
That is our system, which works well for us.
Now, we respect other countries' system(s).
And we are committed to helping other countries
follow the money of their own citizens that
try to hide their money in other jurisdictions.
We are committed to assisting those countries,
and we will continue to do everything that
we can to assist those countries.
However, the cost of implementing the Common
Reporting Standards is going to be very high
on our financial system.
And we're going to do it.
But fear-I mean, nobody has put onto the table
what it represents for a small country to
ensure that you commit to certain standards-because
other countries need that information; you
don't.
There is a large cost in terms of operations
for banks if they're going to exchange information.
Our taxing authority can barely collect taxes
in Panama.
I mean, we have our own problems of tax evasion
that we're working hard at conquering.
Now, we don't only need to concentrate now
on strengthening our taxing authorities in
order for them to collect the taxes that we
need to improve the livelihoods of Panamanians,
but now we need to make sure we strengthen
our tax authorities so that they can share
information with the rest of the world, with
countries that are a lot more powerful and
have a lot more resources than we do.
Now, we're going to do it.
We think it's fair that we do it.
But you need to know there is a cost involved
here.
And that is something that I think needs to
be brought into the table at some point, because
it's like-it's like developed countries-and
I understand the need for additional resources,
and I understand the need to go after your
own citizens that find whatever way to evade
taxes.
And so international legislation has just
been getting stronger to move that fence,
and in the process you're setting up some
standards to the rest of the world that are
standards-that bear a high cost to your own
system at the-at the cost of your people,
at the cost of money you need for development.
So I just wish-since you're in that area,
you know, I just wish that that reality was
also placed on the table.
Now, regarding are we willing to do something
more than just committing to the bare minimum,
yes.
I would love to see my country become a leader
in terms of transparency.
And this is something that we've debated.
Locally, we've installed an international
committee of experts as-last Friday, we installed
it-as part of the measures that we've taken
to respond to the information that has come
out through the Panama Papers and as a part
of our commitment to improve our system, committee
to be co-chaired by Nobel Peace Prize Joseph
Stiglitz.
Now, we all know where Professor Stiglitz's
views are in terms of transparency and in
terms of development.
And we are committed to just waiting for the
recommendations of that committee and see
what information they provide there that will
help us be better.
And, yes, I would love to be at the forefront.
But you've got to understand, just committing
to what we've committed, it's not an easy
thing.
We are having to face questions of whether
we devote money to education or we devote
money to the standards.
It's not an easy-it's not an easy position
to be in.
But, yes, we're committing, and we are working
in that direction.
CUNNINGHAM: Well, we've just crossed the 9:30
hour.
And so, as I-as we bring matters to a close,
let me note that in this country we have a
long tradition of vice presidents who use
the job as a platform for other jobs.
(Laughter.)
We have a more recent tradition of secretaries
of state, foreign ministers, even women secretaries
of state using that as a position for further
jobs.
And I commend that to Panama.
(Laughter.)
Thank you all.
Thank you all for-thank you for joining us
here.
Thank you all.
Please join me in welcoming and thanking the
vice president.
(Applause.)
SAINT MALO: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
(Applause.)
(END)